Being cast on Game of Thrones can be a mixed
blessing.
On one hand, acting in HBO's hottest series
can seriously boost your acting résumé.
On the other hand, given the show's history,
you're probably going to get killed off sooner
or later — as this long list of casualties
can attest.
Here's a look at some of the major characters
who have died on the show, and where the actors
who played them are today.
Harry Lloyd - Viserys Targaryen
He was supposed to be the true King of Westeros,
but Viserys Targaryen was the first main character
to meet his maker on Game of Thrones, when
Khal Drogo "crowned" him with molten gold
during season one.
Actor Harry Lloyd has kept himself busy since
dying on Game of Thrones, continuing to act
on television and in movies like The Theory
of Everything.
His next project is a starring role in the
2018 Starz sci-fi thriller series Counterpart.
Mark Addy - Robert Baratheon
After a hunting trip gone wrong in season
one, King Robert Baratheon, first of his name,
died, prompting his best friend Ned Stark
to take action against the machinations of
Cersei and Joffrey.
Since leaving Thrones, star Mark Addy has
surfaced on several television series, including
Great Expectations and The Syndicate.
More recently, Addy appeared in the 2016 miniseries
Jericho, and as a detective in the 2016 crime
drama series New Blood.
Sean Bean - Ned Stark
After Robert's death, Ned Stark tried to take
control, sending a letter to Robert's brother,
Stannis, inviting him to come take his rightful
place on the throne.
Unfortunately for Ned, Cersei was two steps
ahead of him, and Ned famously lost his head
on the executioner's block at the end of season
one.
"You know which is a sacrifice of himself
for his family, which is a very moving and
touching moment.
And a good way to go, really."
Although Bean has a reputation for being killed
off in many of his projects, he hasn't let
that stop his acting career.
Since Thrones, he's appeared in a variety
of projects, including The Martian and Legends,
and some of his other recent work includes
roles in the six-part BBC miniseries Broken
and the 2017 thriller film Drone.
Jason Momoa - Khal Drogo
Although Khal Drogo was dead essentially from
the moment that old evil witch lady infected
his wound with her fake medicine, his actual
death was much more tragic, as Daenerys had
to suffocate him with a pillow to put him
out of his misery at the end of season one.
Jason Momoa's brief Game of Thrones tenure
served him well in Hollywood, leading to win
the role of Aquaman in the DC Extended Universe
films Batman v Superman, Justice League, and
2018's Aquaman solo adventure.
And Momoa seems like he's enjoying the ride.
"Yahoo!"
Gethin Anthony - Renly Baratheon
Following King Robert's death, his younger
brother Renly attempted to claim the throne.
Renly had one of the largest armies in the
Seven Kingdoms and was beloved by everyone.
Everyone except his brother Stannis, however,
who used black magic to murder Renly in season
two.
After Game of Thrones, actor Gethin Anthony
appeared in the 2014 film Copenhagen as well
as the popular series Call The Midwife, then
demonstrated his range by playing Charles
Manson in the NBC period crime drama Aquarius.
He also provided the voice of Gil Brodie in
the video game Mass Effect: Andromeda.
Oona Chaplin - Talisa Maegyr
Standing in for the book character of Jeyne
Westerling, Talisa Maegyr married Robb Stark,
the King in the North.
Unfortunately, Robb was already engaged to
the granddaughter of Lord Walder Frey, who
exacted his revenge by murdering Talisa at
the Red Wedding in season three.
After Game of Thrones, Oona Chaplin starred
in the 2014 miniseries The Crimson Field and
an episode of the popular television show
Black Mirror, as well as the 2015 movie The
Longest Ride.
Some of her latest projects include starring
roles in the 2017 Spanish comedy film As We
Like It, and the British drama series Taboo.
Richard Madden - Robb Stark
The King in the North, Robb Stark met his
end beside his beloved Talisa, taking a knife
to the heart from the traitorous Roose Bolton.
It was a traumatic way for actor Richard Madden
to end his time on the show.
"I managed to get on the plane, covered in
fake blood.
I was kinda upset at the end of the whole
job.
I kinda looked like I murdered someone and
got on the flight."
Following his exit from Game of Thrones in
2014, Madden appeared in the series Medici:
Masters of Florence and as the Prince in the
2015 live-action Disney adaptation of Cinderella.
More recently, Madden can be seen in the 2017
Amazon original series Oasis.
Michelle Fairley - Catelyn Stark
Though Catelyn dedicated her life to protecting
her children, she died at the Red Wedding
believing she had failed them all.
Since her terrible death in season three,
actress Michelle Fairley has stayed busy with
projects including the television series Resurrection
and the movie In the Heart of the Sea, as
well as the Starz miniseries The White Princess.
Jack Gleeson - Joffrey Baratheon
Thankfully, the reign of psychopathic boy
king Joffrey Baratheon's came to an early
end.
Joffrey married the widowed Margaery Tyrell,
but his reputation as an evil jerk preceded
him, so her grandmother protected her by slipping
some fast-acting poison into his cup at the
reception.
Jack Gleeson retired from screen acting after
Game of Thrones, but he remains involved in
the arts.
He founded Collapsing Horse Theatre Company
in Ireland, which won an award for their puppet
show Bears in Space at the 2016 1st Irish
Theatre Festival in New York City.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!